pas donc vous entendre jean bart c'est
quand vous êtes la nouvelle maire
écologiste de strasbourg mais d'abord on
va regarder votre portrait 7 avec audrey
états elle sera la première maire
écologiste de strasbourg pourtant il ya
quelques mois
son visage était quasi inconnu du grand
public soutenu par les communistes
jeanne bars et guillon 39 ans recueille
41 7% des suffrages et signe une
victoire surprise sur les socialistes
avec qui elle n'a pas réussi à s'allier
spécialiste du droit environnemental
elle est conseillère municipale et
métropolitaine depuis 2014
elles quittent l'exécutif de
l'eurométropole avec fracas quatre ans
plus tard pour signifier son opposition
au contournement ouest de strasbourg
sa première mesure en tant que maire
sera choc elle aussi symboliquement posé
un acte fort autour d'une déclaration
d'état d'urgence climatique que je
proposerai au conseil municipal pour
marquer cette priorité qui doit irriguer
l'ensemble de nos politiques publiques
municipales
strasbourg est déjà la première ville
cyclable de france elle veut en faire la
capitale européenne de la transition
écologique
[Musique]
et bonjour jeanne marseillan merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous depuis à
strasbourg dont vous allez devenir
demain officiellement je la nouvelle
maire première campagne sur votre nom
jalbert séguillon première victoire
qu'est ce qui vous a donné envie d'être
maire de strasbourg
en fait depuis depuis une vingtaine
d'années je suis engagée autour des
questions environnementales c'est des
questions de justice sociale et par mes
activités professionnelles et
associatives je le faisais déjà
travaillé nombre d'acteurs ensemble sur
différents territoires notamment entre
la france et l'allemagne
et cet engagement aujourd'hui prendre
une autre forme
six ans d'un mandat entre comme
conseillère municipale et de
l'eurométropole ou serge j'ai pu
constater parfois des avancées mais
encore trop souvent de l'incohérence et
surtout un manque d'ambition vitaly des
enjeux qui sont devant nous et je pense
bien évidemment à l'urgence climatique
mais aussi concernant la lutte contre
les inégalités
donc ce qui m'a donné envie de m'engager
c'est justement plus de cohérence et
plus d'ambition à mettre en oeuvre dans
un bel de travaux et justement vous
parlez d'urgence climatique demain
l'autre lors de votre installation au
conseil municipal vous allez déclaré
strasbourg en état d'urgence climatique
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça signifie
prendre la mesure de l'époque dans
laquelle nous vivons
quand je me suis engagé dans
l'environnement il ya 20 ans on parlait
déjà de du réchauffement climatique et
on disait qu'il fallait y aller
progressivement par petits pas
aujourd'hui ce que nous disent les
scientifiques c'est qu'il nous reste à
peine quelques années pour pouvoir
infléchir la courbe et
nous souhaitons respecter les accords de
paris nice a su prendre des mesures
extrêmement ambitieuse et donc demain
dès le début de mandat lors de mon
installation qui souhaitent poser cet
acte fort quand je souhaite être un acte
fondateur du mandat et qui signifie que
l'eau commence climat sera prise à bras
le corps dans l'ensemble de mes
décisions dans l'ensemble des politiques
publiques municipales et je l'espère
mais trop petit problème de liaison
jeanne marseillan on espère qu'on va
vous retrouver voilà vous à retrouver
vous allez retrouver questions sur
fessenheim et oui parce que c'est la
concordance des temps votre victoire
votre victoire municipale arrive dans la
période de fermeture de la centrale
nucléaire de fessenheim
j'imagine que c'est une satisfaction
pour vous ça n'est pas le cas pour tous
les élus dans la dans la région cette
région d'alsace pour vous pour votre
ville pour cette zone urbaine c'est quoi
l'avenir énergétique de strasbourg
ça ressemble à quoi oui vous avez raison
et une convergence d'événements qui
montre bien que nous sommes au seuil de
changement profond de notre société
effectivement des changements politiques
des changements aussi dans le mode de
production et de consommation
et bien sûr la fermeture de fessenheim
la plus vieille centrale française en
est un symbole très fort dans cette
danse est alsace quelques ajustements
pionnière en matière d'écologie
l'écologie politique et donc on doit se
tourner vers l'avenir et ce que j'ai
porté avec mon équipe c'est de pouvoir
répondre aux besoins du quotidien des
personnes et donc ça passe bien sûr par
répondre à leurs besoins énergétiques
on sait qu après ce jour par exemple un
quart des personnes vip en précarité en
situation de précarité énergétique donc
il faut pouvoir répondre à cet enjeu
social mais il faut aussi prendre le
virage de la transition énergétique pour
aller d'amener nagy des cargos tpr a
plus plus local alors pendant quelques
temps quelques temps cette énergie vous
allez devoir aller la chercher ailleurs
et elle est encore un peu carbonée mais
alors cela a été un processus long mais
c'est pour ça qu'il ne faut plus perdre
de temps alors je me permets de dire que
la centrale de fessenheim présenté
depuis des années de très nombreux
dysfonctionnements de fêtes 2,2 son âge
qu'elle était très souvent à l'arrêt et
aucun genre de tirlemont ne s'est pas
arrêté pour autant par france il nous
faut anticiper cette conversion est
notamment pour accompagner la mutation
des emplois il s'agit pas d'opposer la
non plus transition énergétique et
emploi moi j'ai un très bon exemple de
l'autre côté du rhin avec le manager
solberg qui a engagé des transitions
énergétiques connaissance avec à la clé
de la création d'emploi local de manière
le meilleur merci donc en fait ce sont
salées en jeu l'avenir et c'est aussi un
enjeu fort pour notre foi notre économie
est justement puisque vous parler
d'économie il ya eu quelques inquiétudes
du monde économique à strasbourg du
patronat notamment de voir arriver à la
tête de la ville une écologiste comment
vous allez rassurer ce monde économique
et comment concrètement vous allez faire
en sorte qu écologie et économies soient
compatibles en fait économie écologie
sont déjà compatibles
en tant que professionnels de
l'environnement la campagne depuis des
années les entreprises engagées dans une
démarche de responsabilité sociétale
maintenant
ce qu'il nous faut réussir c'est de
conserver l'ensemble des forces en
mettant tous les acteurs du monde
économique
autour de la table les représentants des
entreprises les chambres consulaires
l'artisanat le commerce l'industrie et
main dans la main pouvoir unique et et
pouvoir rêver avec des orientations
claires sur des filières d'avenir on
vient d'évoquer la transition
énergétique
on pourrait parler l'économie circulaire
et travaux publics exemplaire de l'éco
construction des matériaux biosourcés ou
encore de l'agriculture locale et bien
tous ces chantiers je souhaite que les
ouvrir main dans la main avec le monde
économique qui est en attendent aussi
que les pouvoirs publics puissent
accompagner cette transition
nous évoquions j'adorerais qu'il y en a
eu juste avant avec michaël delafosse
que la question de la gratuité des
transports il est pour une gratuité
intégrale
je crois que vous êtes plus modérée sur
le sujet mascarte à 13 jours nous nous
avons une tarification solidaire qui
permet à personne de payer leur
abonnement en fonction de leurs revenus
donc ce qui est un système équitable
mais il faut réactualiser les barrages
des tarifications et moi ce que j'ai
proposé
la technique on vous en retrouve
derrière vous à retrouver presque a
presque retrouvé
c'est bon on vous a retrouvé on vous
entend en tout cas si vous c'est la
gratuité des noms on n'attend pas on a
un petit peu du mal à vous entendre jean
bart séguillon
on va pas le cacher on est en train de
résoudre ce petit problème technique
on parlait donc delà de la question de
la gratuité des transports des trains -
fabrice sur ce oui parce que par
séquences on avait tout à l'heure
effectivement alors qu'on a face à nous
deux élus de gauche
a bouna note de la france une diagonale
même avec deux stratégies à ces
différentes deux approches assez
différente sur la politique du transport
ce sont des engagements électoraux on
l'a vu pour le nouveau maire de
montpellier il a pris un engagement ils
rappellent qu'ils valent ils entendent
obtenir avec une grande grande fermeté
même si localement il n'est pas soutenu
par tout le monde
la nouvelle maire de strasbourg elle est
semble-t-il sur une logique qui tient au
revenu et à la classe d'âge ce qui
signifie bien que 1 même si écologistes
et socialistes sont en mesure de
travailler ensemble
il peut y avoir un certain nombre de
divergences encore et de l'ajustement a
apporté dans l'eure dans leur politique
au quotidien parce que là on est
vraiment sur des sujets ultra quotidien
que ce soit pour les montpellierains oui
simple strasbourg juin et on va essayer
de retourner à strasbourg est ce que
vous nous entendez jeanne marseille en
super alors on va continuer cette
interview on va continuer à parler
d'écologie 1 le président de la
république qui s'est exprimée en sur ce
sujet au lendemain des municipales il a
retenu la quasi totalité des
propositions de la convention citoyenne
il promet même de référendum sur ce
sujet est ce que vous avez senti en
tournant écologique de la part du
président de la république est en plein
poumon écologique de la part du
président de la république images et on
prie je pense très fortement un tournant
écologique dans la société et qui est
formidable dans fait une équipe
initiative de la convention et citoyen
pour le climat c'est de voir que des
personnes tirées au sort pour tous qu'on
leur donne des informations d'experts
qu'on leur explique les enjeux et bien
assez naturellement à au bout de
quelques mois de travail
elle se mettre d'accord sur des mesures
qui sont ambitieux et qui peuvent
effectivement dérouté parce que elle
elle implique des changements de
pratiques et donc je pense que c'est ça
qui est intéressant dans cette danse a
fini sciatique évidemment j'appelle de
mes voeux la mise en oeuvre de
l'ensemble de ces propositions que je
trouve tout à fait tout à fait cohérente
et pertinente pour un certain nombre
elle correspond tout à fait aux cons g
que je mets en place que je compte
mettre en place à à strasbourg et que et
que d'autres collègues notamment
écologie mettre en oeuvre dans les
grandes villes françaises
moi j'ai une petite question pour le
maire et son bureau il paraît que vous
allez descendre du 8e au premier étage
c'est vrai ça les tentes des 9e voyait à
meaux pour continuer sur cette interview
en d'emmanuel macron 1 ce matin dans 'la
dans la presse quotidienne régionale il
parle de décentralisation il tend la
main aux élus il dit qu'il faut des
concertations entre le gouvernement et
les élus de tous les territoires
est ce que vous vous êtes prêts à
participer à ces concertations jeanne
marseille ont écouté il ya des espaces
de dialogue avec l'enfant dans l'as des
territoires bien sûr que j'y
participerai parce que je souhaite
porter la voile et d'électro paul je
souhaite porter la voix des territoires
je complétais aujourd'hui les chaînes
tactiques pour pour agir sur les dons
jeu de transition écologique ineos nu de
justice sociale et de démocratie
par contre j'ai envie de près des années
de plus tôt d'un mouvement de
recentralisation où on a quasiment le
gouvernement
en place a quasiment les collectivités
sous tutelle un avec des mesures
drastiques notamment dans la limitation
de nos dépenses de fonctionnement
j'ai envie de dire que les faire
peut-être appel à la concertation
correspond à une volonté concrète et non
pas encore à l'événement qu'est ce que
vous demandez vous vous demandez plus de
compétences ou vous demandez simplement
les moyens d'exercer les compétences
dont vous disposez déjà ce serait déjà
bien d'avoir les moyens d'exercer nos
compétences avec encore une fois le des
besoins et notamment des besoins sociaux
qui explosent sur nos territoires donc
on ne peut pas à la fois demandé aux
collectivités de répondre localement
assez à ses besoins nous sommes prêts
salle par et ne pas nous donner les
moyens de le faire avec la suppression
de la taxe d'habitation nous avons aussi
un levier fiscal extrêmement importante
qui a disparu et donc quand je parle de
mise sous tutelle et que nous perdons en
fait part d'autonomie qui nous permet de
tout simplement mettre en oeuvre notre
action publique locale donc oui on
pourra envisager ensuite plus de
compétences mais commençons déjà par
j'attends que l'état qui puisse
débloquer les moyens et surtout qu'ils
nous laissent travailler en autonomie
sur sur nos territoires
bien sûr de manière concertée mais aussi
de manière ambiguë questions politiques
sur sur strasbourg vous avez pris la
mairie de strasbourg sans les
socialistes
vous avez refusé de vous allier à eux
alors que je crois que vous parlez de
catherine trautmann comme d'un modèle
est ce que vous allez travailler avec
elle et avec les socialistes durant ce
mandat ou est ce que pour vous ce sont
des opposants mais on a clairement
pendant cette campagne plus contacter
des convergences qu'on a aussi constaté
des divergences sur des questions de
méthode sur sur des projets sur des
questions font mais bien des projets
routiers des projets autoroutiers la
question la question de la mise en
oeuvre climatique
donc je suppose que catherine trautmann
créé raconte son groupe et ensuite
nous discuterons moi je souhaite de
toute façon mettre en place une
gouvernance renouvelée au niveau
municipal et travailler en bonne
intelligence avec enfants des groupes
politiques avec plus de collégialité
avec des commissions thématiques qui
permettront à l'ensemble des groupes
politiques de participer à la
construction des défusions municipales
dernière question jeanne verser quand
même ça peut être compliqué vous êtes au
tout début de votre mandat qu est ce qui
vous fera dire dans six ans que vous
avez réussi votre mandat de maire de
strasbourg a ajouté si on a réussi à
enclencher une transformation à
strasbourg si j'ai réussi à faire en
sorte que le strasbourg au niveau
national mais aussi au niveau européen
puisse réparé par son exemplarité
notamment dans la question de la manière
par l'aele et le chantier je vais
enclenché dès cet été sur une nouvelle
page de notre urbanisme local de la
verticalisation de la déminéralisation
plus d espace pour pour les cyclistes
pour pour les piétons et tout cela en
luttant contre les inégalités et bien
français derrière avoir réussi en tout
cas à mettre en place mais les objectifs
et on aura l'occasion d'en reparler
jeunes vers ces gains on espère vous
recevoir à nouveau dans cette matinale
merci beaucoup d'avoir été en direct
avec nous depuis strasbourg merci
fabrice veysseyre redon et on passe tout
de suite au club des territoires